all right the last word with ebon tiss
we are alive what is going on sir how
you been man
I've been amazing in the last like oh
how long was it yeah about 12 hours ago
it's been a good evening last night so I
got the chance to see the greatness ah
chalice and that's all I'm gonna say
sure if you guys want some videos man is
sort of India near to ear nice nice
so non-spoiler accepted review is Wow to
devil Wow alright one last quick
non-spoiler question I know it's hard
okay alright so ranking ranking let's
just talk some raking let's just whiz it
in is it is it in the pantheon of
greatness top five it's gotta be up
there
mmm-hmm it's gotta be in discussion it's
a different movie and I want to watch it
again because you know like I want to
focus on it more on the second time I'm
gonna see it again Sunday but it's
different like it depends on what like
you're going for I mean yeah infinity
worse was theosis movie I've heard
people can't describe it that way and it
absolutely was this is this is a
different movie but this is it's hard to
rank because honestly this is like the
but like the best series finale I've
ever seen
Wow or like a TV show because you've had
got 22 episodes
and this is you see your series finale
like and it's phase 3 I mean technically
phase 3 goes through spider-man but um
say that ok I'm kid confident I'm
getting real coffee and for everybody's
knowledge there is no post-credits yes
shout out the arm addict he told me the
same thing and when I tried to like
complain here's I know trust me you'll
be satisfied am i ok yeah no
post-credits ok it's don't need him
so yeah fair enough I see you saturday I
can't wait to talk to you about I see it
again Sunday and then also within the
same day on Sunday
we have Game of Thrones episode
three whoa what's it like that's an
emotional rollercoaster of a day with
those two together like I'm gonna just
be like fried yeah let me tell you I'm
low-key I'm dreading that more like I'm
just I'm not ready for that because if
obviously if you see in the last episode
you'll know you have and anybody who's
fans of Game of Thrones it's like they
are setting us up in vintage Game of
Thrones fashion for the tragedy so we
know that yeah it just sucks oh these
are beloved characters we've all seen
these character arcs we've been with
these guy was over eight years now like
you've seen the growth and to know that
we could lose so many of them is like oh
man anyway yeah that's all I can say we
got Game of Thrones for me at NFL Draft
this week it's just geek in sports and
just all types of busyness for me it's
just overwhelming yes too much shutting
down yeah so we got this uh this destiny
stuff to talk about some your shooter
stuff to talk about
yeah we're literally like this not
talking about like the Loki no planning
podcast right here I text them last
night like 9:30 because I know you're up
and I'm getting that home from the movie
and be like we still doing the podcast
tomorrow yeah I was like okay absolutely
we don't miss a beat man good once we
get under that mic is synergy once again
so let's talk about this thing man
before we do I want one other piece I
finished my first playthrough of Sakura
in that last boss lose that last boss
fight was nine damn minutes long nine
minutes but why did you watch it
yes salute you in your persistence like
let me tell you about that game watching
you play that game it is such a mental
marathon it is it is the epitome of
gaming toughness is what I call that
game and it will break you and one thing
about you is you got that cool calm
demeanor so it's like it actually you
like the sage like you you talked
yourself through and even when you did
that run didn't you kind of tweet you
were like I'm just gonna do a practice
run get myself kind of
yeah like I did he beats it it's like it
went like I mean the last boss is a pain
there's no question it's ever gonna be
an easy fight in one of those games and
this one is no different it's got
multiple phases to it sadly in the
phases kind of escalate and stuff like
that and it was kind of the way like it
was described in the fight last week but
just to a different level because last
week was like a Dark Souls fight and
reminded me that one of the most of them
because there's no pairing no blocking
when you fight this demon there's no
anything with most of what you've
learned the mechanics in the game this
fight is every single boss you've fought
in the game combined in one being like
precise timing looking to read their
moves like all the little pieces are
smashed together in one oh and it's just
like hey you get through one phase okay
now you're on Phase two I got whooped in
Phase two okay let me go through phase
one again not crap I just died in phase
one and it's just kind of building
towards a guy and I worked on it some
like off stream and I had a little short
stream here and there that stream was
like like 35 minutes when I did it
because it was short but I had worked on
some tourist feeling comfortable Zakaria
I was getting through phase one
comfortably alright it was getting
through Phase two like pretty consistent
comfortable it's like and I know if I
can do that it's if I can put the pieces
together I know I can make it happen
it's like and then phase two happens
like okay I'm getting through phase two
okay we're getting close now ice know I
got a lot of heals left we're in Phase
three
oh crap okay so it's like in my mind I'm
like a duck on a pond maybe okay on the
outside bill and losing my crap on the
inside so my like my heart rates
probably keep it together you keep it
together I get like I said that is a
tremendous feat that game man I mean a
four phase in boss and then I'm seeing
the unlockables and then you have to
have the perfect Perry's do these damage
phase I'm just like yeah I'm gonna watch
over later today I just don't need that
level of stress in my life bro like I
give you credit like that thing is like
tension man all day shout out to you
shout out the Attic inspired him cuz I
got mine in the next day and I want to
give you props because he was he was
talking slick in your streams let's just
call out Lord addict now you talk in
your street oh you didn't beat
oh you're doing this wrong and then my
boy he bounces the soloist did it first
so game addict get your stuff together
alright it's the guy right but it's it's
been quite a journey it's like that game
is fun and there's bosses I didn't even
face there's a completely different
ending so and it's honestly one of those
that now I've gone through it once I
would I would play it again and it would
be certain things would be faster
there's one I would have to learn but I
I've seen different views different and
now that I've actually beaten it I kind
of watched more like reviews in-depth
spoiler in King's bosses things like
that that I had tried to avoid because
I'd honestly gone pretty much blind on
the whole thing and like everybody has
different opinions like his souls better
is you know I was lucky hero and things
like that and honestly I think one of
the videos I watched said it well I
can't remember which one so shout out to
you said it not trying to steal it
for those who are fans of the series
they were able to make you get the
feeling you probably had the first time
you played the series okay feeling of
like having to learn to get the feeling
of like I hate the term get good but the
feeling of having to truly learn what
the game wants to teach you and to gives
us through senses of accomplishment in
those fists points because if it was
dark soul story if you played Dark Souls
1 dark souls 2 and blood-borne Dark
Souls 3 you get a feel and the people
who are good at those are gonna still be
good at a dark souls game they just have
to learn maybe the nuances of the newest
game but they're gonna have a pretty
good idea this one basically broke you
to learn you had to learn a completely
new style it flipped it on set and they
were able to still keep their their
difficulty so people the sense of their
the core feeling of a game but in a
completely different feel and honestly
for me I I had a blast so for me on sec
hero that's that's definitely a high
game for the year for sure absolutely
sorry vodka just had to say that as I
actually crossed the finish line this
week at least one day haha that's a
bigger college me now you got a puff
chess out that one
but in the world of destiny we got some
topics and I think I'm gonna be letting
you lead some of these discussions but
we will get some of this going here sure
you want me to lead with her I've been
lately hey we gotta we gotta have
opinions I've been all like oh I got the
positives out of the way I got the goods
now we got a I'm gonna we're gonna have
some tough talks about a couple things
so so iron banner has been live this
week in destiny for those you guys
they've been living under a rock double
Valor is available now triple is
available for the weekend they do touch
on one thing they said last week we've
covered some sandbox tuning arsim
sandbox super tuning that's on its way
for destiny to update to point to point
to form a we don't have a date on that
one yet and today we will be looking at
some changes currently in development
for season of opulence which is a bit
further out read on to learn how
pinnacle hand canons of destiny will be
changing interesting
they said balance the bike mmm-hmm at
the release of destiny to for second to
Pinnacle weapons be became available
player for players to earn in
competitive each weapon has a unique
quest requiring mastery of the WebP and
cannons to completes there's been a lot
of feedback on how the crucible hand
cannons stand above most other weapons
in the sandbox today we'll be going
through some of the balance changes
planned for season of opulence so you've
got until opulence that giving you time
they wanted to start this conversation
early to ensure players understood the
changes were coming even if they were
still on the path to acquire these
rewards here's the Destiny team so I'm
gonna let you take this like I want you
to break down what the changes are cuz
you're the you're the crucible guys
let's see yes so we want to talk about
what strife from a dev team part right
alright so here's a preview alright yeah
yeah alright so here we go so
magnificent how the unique perk on these
weapons is to effective it works in a
neutral setting and rewards players for
getting precision shots something they
would have done naturally as a result
the time to kill the game shifts to meet
this new benchmark and players feel that
the great majority of primary weapons in
destiny - cannot compete with these
pinnacle weapons
our current plan is to make Lunas how
and not forgotten the only 150 rpm
engine is 150 used to be 180
they will maintain some aspects of their
current behavior while talk while taking
on the firing speed and damage of the
150 round per minute hand cannons
magnificent Howell will also be adjusted
so that increases only body shot damage
resulting in two head shot one body shot
kill magnificent how will still give an
advantage due to requiring less
precision hits for optimal time to kill
like we do whenever destiny gameplay
involves we will be watching the
conversation starting today on our plan
changes we'll continue collecting
feedback once these changes go live
during this beginning the season
opulence if you have feedback now please
make sure to sound off in the destiny to
forum right here on fuzzy net oh boy we
got a lot to unpack here as the cops
class by me they have a letter can they
work if they working but um yeah man I
mean I'll let me let you start off cuz I
got a lot to say about this and um you
know I'm the crucible thing but I I'm
curious on your perspective first as far
as you know where do you feet what do
you feel about this you know do you know
about the changes do you think this is
fair do you think it's too harsh you
know where where you at I know I know
you're play competitive a lot like that
but just in the general based on what
you've read and how it sounds I'm just
looking over
firing rates on some other ones because
somebody was asking trying to see what
the cuz born is 150 150 yeah yeah yeah
so they think that going into the the
one Luna's how it's very powerful
formally 180s that are now going to go
into the 150 class oh god spare rations
is 150 as well what does it sound like
to you
what does it feel like to you I know we
may be you indifference that so I mean
they have a tough balance like they are
very apparent in crucible
especially when you get into quick play
and it's kind of a tough thing for
people who are trying to acquire those
guns to go in and face like half of a
team that has it already when you're
trying to get it in quick play I mean
you can take it in quick play it's
totally fair but it is definitely gonna
put you at a decent advantage if you
like work to actually get the gun
so somebody who doesn't have it at all
so I mean it is a good gun but also the
journey it takes to get these things is
not easy actually not forgotten not
forgotten is next to impossible for most
people mm-hmm so that one is the fact
that there and from what I'm seeing now
the perk adjustment is one thing now and
actually seems a bit more that totally
changes it's time to kill for sure 150
rpm
what were they 140 s 140 s
I believe I mean because I think it's uh
what we got yeah 140 s are better
doubled stuff like that yeah what was it
what were they wear that 180s before is
that what they were they were 180s okay
so they it would fall in that archetype
I believe um I think my fee since is 180
yeah I believe so basically like you
know the faster fire rate you know they
180 tended to be the meta as far as hand
cannons in PvE yeah I'll come 180 that
can to tap you I mean yes so it's not a
reaction speed of like any other late I
can to tap almost but my go figure it's
gonna be slower and I get a hit hit all
my shots and what I mean go figure a
blast furnace if I do truly to tap
somebody with my go figure it feels
really good and that's pretty damn quick
but if you can to tap with a 180 one of
the faster style hand cannons it is a
point of it stuff but also in turn the
journey to get there is hard in taking
away the reward to get there's also and
that's this is where I was like bungee
you screwed either way so it's like they
have a gun that might be slightly out of
whack but to a point where I don't
honestly I don't have like a great
answer because like it's your crapped
either way because the person the perk
is the weird one though because you take
magnificent hell so that increases only
body shot damage so it can do
to headshot one body shot scene I need
three instead of two right definitely
changes the speed of it slightly a lot
which puts it into three tap class which
are armed you know currently you know
there's a bunch of other you know one
40s that kind of can three tap now so
it's kind of in that thing so it's kind
of like a double thing cuz you got the
the RPM change and then you have the
perk adjustment kind of deal but oh I
was gonna jump in here if you don't mind
no they don't worry cuz like for me it's
like I'm just I'm torn him sitting there
thinking through and I was thinking
about it yesterday I was like I honestly
don't know cause like touching what
those people work for is rough
especially not forgotten because getting
a 15-2 getting to legend the way things
have been especially if you think about
on PC too is like it is such a brutal
place to be in so touching you award
that you set up in there and I think
honestly shout out to Tassie that I'll
let you do it because you might like
shout out to Tassie his thought on it
this morning was mostly just the fact
that if you did have this theory you
should have done it within about two
weeks not so absolutely absolutely I
mean listen I'm kinda it's a probably I
think we're actually the same boat
Connor I am torn because it's like look
yeah I know how I feel about PvP and at
the end of the day it's like the mold as
itself right now is not in a good place
as far as a population is concerned yeah
and you know you you introduce these
pinnacle weapons right you introduce
these things these transfer people like
myself who are hardcore
who you know really want to play
competitive in crime for these kind of
Pinnacle weapons and again I can I gotta
speak from two perspectives though
there's the PC PC perspective and then
it's the console perspective right now
on PC when I'm in the cruise when I'm in
comp yes there's gonna be times where I
call against teams of Howells teams of
you know I'm saying not forgotten yeah
it can get sweaty there's no doubt about
it but I've never felt because of the
way the the weapon is designed it's very
stable is very accurate yes as the
option to tap once those perks and all
that it's enabled but the weakness in my
opinion was always
great right if I kept distance and I'm
saying shot the militiamen swings you
know and other little you know stop
pulses and stuff I could always handle
them you know I'm saying and I'm not
trying to make this a get good situation
weapon is from but did I feel like oh my
god it's nothing but Luna's house and
this oh my god I personally know if I'm
just gonna speak from my experience I
never felt the weapon was so ridiculous
that you know it had to be something
done now
shout out to um the black link shot to
plan that scene those guys he has got a
fantastic video out right now and me and
him are kind of on exact same page where
the issue is you know I fell out from
what I'm hearing cuz me and you remember
we made this you know we made to jump on
PC so console I heard it's running wild
that's where it's running well okay so
cause so here's the problem with console
because of one because of bloom on hand
cannons on console that affects it more
like Luna and and not forgotten they
kind of get out of that within the 180
class so they exempt from man on console
mmm so that's why they even stand out
more where you have more of the bloom
with the 140s and other rpm classes you
said I'm saying and now what they're
saying is it's gonna retain the the
factors of 180 on console so that it's
not gonna have the bloom effects you're
not gonna have to be missing your shots
and all that so retain the major feel
but I guess I guess II at the end of the
day I just struggle with a double nerf
you know I'm saying an RPM change and a
perk change and then we're also not
forgetting a lot of people use this gun
in PvE so as the damage increases like
it was really effective so now that
changes and I'm just I'm just over
mindset like Tasi so it's like this gun
is stream lis hard to grind for like if
you look at this like I'm almost close
to getting it now on PC yeah and I mean
the hand cannon kills the the headshots
the solar kills that the getting the
fabled ranking the legend whatever it it
this is not easy
yeah this I can understand again if this
gun was completely broken if this gun
was
just raining Tara you know I don't see
it so I struggle with this man
especially with crucible not be in a
good place so I mean you know they felt
the need to do this I'm not really
pleased with it you know I may be one
one of the nerfs may be shot the Forte
so yeah it's a crime role took me
forever yeah it's it's it's tough man
and I feel bad like these people you
know putting this work as a pinnacle
weapon and they're gonna say hey you
casual eyes in this now you know I mean
you get completely casual eyes in this
and this is one of those things where
just like I don't I don't think this was
necessarily the right way to go right
now especially with crucible in the
state that crucible is in it's like
every day and we'll get into the revelry
in a bit you know saying yeah it's like
as a crucible player every day I feel
like boom another punch to the gut boom
another slap to the face I feel like the
stepchild like I feel like that I love
crucible bro I love it I mean I know
it's not perfect but it's my favorite
thing and all to see it not being played
and to see it you know in a bad spot
struggle with it man absolutely struggle
with it so we shall see what happens you
know and apparently they still gonna
take feedback and this is gonna debut on
um
season half of opulence here we go yeah
I mean that's kind of a thing and I
think taxi was it's there-there slowness
to act on some of this stuff if they
have data if they see that it's like
it's either the testing upfront or their
testing crew doesn't have a wide variety
of like skill levels for PvP to either
see how this thing's gonna pan out and
it's not an easy thing to like test
without getting in millions of people's
hands but I mean I am also kind of with
you I see it sometimes but even on PC I
don't see it everywhere and again that
may be a pc vs consoles things so I mean
more people on PC and maybe sweaty and
they're like oh god I'm not gonna go
grind for it here but if you're saying
it's like everywhere on console just
because the player base is bigger maybe
or something like that especially even
Lunas
mm-hmm I don't know but yeah it's like
the double hit is weird it's like they
slowed it down mm-hmm some won't fire as
fast but the fact what actually bugs me
mmm is that it increases only body shot
damage so if somebody is actually good
at hitting precision shots you make them
not actually have that which is a weird
weird thing in my head honestly so
here's the other thing I want to forget
at this point too is like dude there are
other options out there like shout the
40 he's on it
Ace of Spades is out here you got
reclose out here vigilance is strong
you've got a lot of options that can
still compete with this thing and then I
believe um even if you don't get it do
it you can get service revolver I
believe what's in that same class I
believe it's like 180 rpm malfeasance
I've been rockin that's in 180 there are
viable options that if you don't have
these guns you can compete and be just
as dominant so again I don't feel it was
like and divide by the volume getting is
that they must have some statistic on
console yeah
and that they are so worried about this
on console and again why not buff other
things you don't say why not I just
don't this is a hard weapon to get did
to really knock this down a couple of
pegs you really not UD incentivizing
people to do that grind when people are
not playing competitive crucible like
that anyway so you know I I struggle bro
I really do struggle with this one yeah
I was we'll see how it goes
we'll see what more people honestly like
oh wait for people like fallout like us
to cross let those guys weigh in see
what their thoughts are when this
actually goes live see what they have
the changes are but they've also got so
it's a weird balance right now it's kind
of odd yeah and then shut up I want to
shout out too dramatic
he said Trust is my goal yeah if you got
a good role for us you you in a good
spot you know shout out to a coach and
ami said the lo TT keys are fun but it's
like bro like shoutout to Gore talker
like PC asus is a space it means way
more dominant because at the end of the
day that's a big I can aim down sights
and I got my radar with ace of spades
you move
know what you're doing that's a huge
advantage natural awareness advantage
then if you get the momentum or e and
you get in the book Oh like is a space
out here like it's really doing some
things out here so yes again like was I
like oh my god those lunar house so no
like those that I just haven't really
had that complaint it's not like Oh make
it like a little different issue in
crucible like but I mean it is a pain in
the butt to get it and I didn't never to
me maybe I'm not in the sweaty playlist
or whatever knows but even if you in
comp somewhere you're like yeah
sometimes it's there
mm-hmm but there's still options like I
mean the frozen I mean late there's it
it feels like feels like it feels like a
long time yeah feels like a weird and
that's why I was like Tassie's artic
thoughts were on it word
like I mean opinions on how the guns
gonna work is one thing but just the
timing of the update is just like it
should have been quicker I mean that's
kinda sure with things taking so long or
the data and be like oh well six months
later or crap almost eight mm-hmm just
feels like it takes way too long to make
a change so then people who have like
hey this is my gun my baby I've had it
for like it'd be like taking my go
figure nerfing it now oh that's what I'm
saying
I mean it would be something that's been
in the game for however long it should
be said like if you were gonna change
the way a gun like that works you should
have done it long ago
so exactly that's pretty much I'm not
gonna beat that me no no that's what I
mean it's it's just weird were both on
the same leg I didn't feel like I was
getting slapped upside the head with it
all the time yo I just feel like it's
kind of I mean if they don't touch it
you know I maybe I need to go into comp
and get my bubble up some who knows but
we'll see yeah absolutely
speaking of the next topic we got the
revelry Burton light so last week
revelry orbs were disabled in gambit
game but prime raids competitive
crucible due to an increase in guitar
errors and activity disconnections as
multiple sources of progress for the
verdant light competitive triumphs are
no longer available this team has been
investigating a change basically what
they're saying is
you will probably get it during but
afterwards if you're going for the
emblem they're gonna change the
requirement from 200 orbs basically
you're gonna have to get in quick play
Rumble or the feature play this which is
our in banner we're gonna take it from
200 to 20 so you're not gonna need that
many orbs that might take you like 10
precision kills the pop if you play a
decent amount you'll probably have it
but crucible right now is that somewhere
you want to be served we don't talk
about this because I got some
revelations to debut on glass or door
has been opened so yeah listen bro I I
got to make my fishery statement now
lower third right now scrolling Lord no
official statement on the state of the
crucible currently going live in 3 2 1
we've got him live Johnny all right here
we go
may we listen I'm sorry oh I know I've
been very negative last couple of books
I know I've been I've been very very
aggressive and agitated with watches
lately when we have the crucible
discussions but the reality is until
further notice lord kognito will not be
playing destiny until the reverie is
over I am done with the reverie I want
no parts of the reverie I think this is
a cataclysmic mistake um in in Bungie
history in awhile it's been it's been a
while it's been a while since I've seen
boneheaded nough Slyke this and the
reason why I say is because again I know
I am in the minority right I know that
the most of you majority you guys you
play PvE play your night falls you play
your strikes you do you gambit cool for
a guy like me PvP is something near and
dear to my heart I am the only person
probably in one of the few people that
get excited when I am banner coming
wrong even when the weapons are terrible
even when everything is as bad as it is
Lord Cognito is like yes I can hear
Saladin say the walls are on the hunt
and I can get my special lockdown thing
you know I play comp I've made the
transition from console to PC I've been
in a good groove I've been grinding I
was so close to getting my Lunas hell of
course but we're not going to talk about
that we're going to talk
reverie and the revelry happened and it
started last last you know last where we
talked about it I thought someone was
hacking my game I didn't know what was
going on I was trying to cat points and
count down and there was just hunters
running around opens vowels and dipping
knees all over the place and I'm like yo
what what's going on like what but did I
not know that people are doing and I saw
what it was it was the infamous grenade
and the reality is if you are a
competitive PvP player right it is so
demoralizing to see people play with
this lack of skill you know I'm saying
it's just this cheese and this spam and
this is the new meta the spam it it's
literally like mayhem is in every aspect
of the game now for PvE you guys I get
it it's fun you're doing these strikes
you're having a blast you're blowing up
stuff you you're going through the
regular get for PvP it is horrible it is
horrifying it is the worst thing like my
competitive soul has been extinguished
it hit with this because it is just the
cheesiest cheap tactics and I refuse to
play like that man I really do and it's
like I said I know I'm probably the only
person crying out here no one's caring
but that's how I feel and I'm not I'm
not gonna do it to my site ride I even
said you know what you know one of them
if you can't beat them join them kind of
deals yeah and I did the nasty meta a
there's the silly loadouts and I'm like
and I refuse to let my ranking just get
its shot out to sake free it is don't
take thank you brother
he said it's demoralizing to watch her
rank trap but rock back about 200 300
points after you know even I've been
playing the right way
and guys are out here getting free lunch
with all these terrible tactics and it's
just it's that I can't do it I can't do
it man and here's the last thing and
forget about not a crucible the last
part of my ramp is just that at the end
of the heavy buzz his face is so far
he's just like oh my god
but like here's a thing it's just then I
look at the rewards let's say if I don't
even wanna do cruise which you know
that's not but let's just say fix your
face the reality is that you know we are
definitely at a point now where it's
like I've really go for our ballasted
that hard you know I'm saying like then
you got the ornaments that only last
during the reverie like whose idea was
this like why a uh it's just a
cataclysmic failure and then it's three
weeks they can't fix the things fast
enough so I'm not doing it
you call me wake me up when it's over
there's a song like before you go go
wake me up with is off of it that's well
that I'm not touching this I refuse
continue II rant over I mean you kind of
nailed a couple of the pieces of the
rebel we're being kind of multiple
strikes against it feels like it's too
long oh you don't have to do the pvp one
to get the herbalist so don't worry
about that mhm
you can do most of the things you need
without it which is good thank God
I would have been even worse but yeah so
like the ornaments they're an orangey
roll that you have to grind a hole that
time to get this currency take 75 per
bucket look it's totally I got a blue
from it I get a blue gun from that thing
I'm like screw that noise I literally
like I was like I'll try a couple mmm
like I got a legendary I got this I got
a blue gun I'm like I'm done why is that
even in that pool why is that even in
there why is it in there and let's be
real like it may be more than just the
árboles for three weeks yeah three weeks
let me have a cosmetic set of armor
which looks better than your normal set
of armor cosmetics that is random that
you're probably not gonna get purse I'm
probably gonna be that good your set
bonus is only gonna work while this
thing's active and then that goes away
your ornament which shouldn't matter if
you do get a full set magically and you
want to wear that
your or your ornaments not even gonna
work in a week and a half exactly what's
the point what is the point what isn't
that the one with like the deer is like
and they change color subclass that
you're using yeah why why if I have it
okay he'll just let the ornament be
there I don't I just stay like why is it
just like the Matic yes exactly
I don't Loki I can't I think this is bad
for me as like remember what was what
was um The Haunted one's name we always
have a forest not I mean what's the name
of the event there it's always calm lost
felt like member like the first fest of
the laws really yeah it's like again
we're it's at that territory for me with
just like I just don't see the
investment I don't see why you know I
mean and then you you I'll be honest
yeah you actually did it for me when you
told me about the herbalist and magic
aid cuz I was all right oh yeah that was
just a another bummer for me and just
the way I hope the park was gonna work
and it didn't so I've been the same camp
as you because I thought that would be
the perfect match game weapon right when
that strike comes yeah everyone would
have you know had a little herbalist and
whatever whatever and then you told me
and I'm like is this one this one's a
failure and and I think what they tried
to be cute and use this as a stopgap
between opulence thinking that this was
gonna be enough meat to hold us that's
not as much breath not as much so I
think now I know we're being Debbie
downers you know it's up so but I have
now is like taking the crazy grenades
into crucible that's broken there's no
question kind of ruins the fun if you
wanted to have a moat if you wanted to
literally have a mode where it worked or
stick crucible abs of the quarter and
its controller clash and up there in
those modes or even just didn't quit
playing general something like that it
works but it was like comp should never
been there
like I will I will truly say when you
turn this on mm-hmm you go grenadiers
into a nightfall oh my god I was having
so much fun she I have to have it in
there in my late-night chat we were
running and sadly just because the boss
is like time gated so you have to have
community faces strange terrain six
minutes 55 seconds dope
over and over and over I got my break a
cos spree mm-hmm I got money
[ __ ] least I've got like two nightfall
ones that I was missing in about two
hours bro I am so happy for you PvE got
guys because destiny grew today just
devs love you guys
I mean it's just everything you guys
want you having fun and it's like I'm
like in the back of the class with this
group of changers that yeah we're cool
like you PvP guys no one cares about you
like and I just sit there and I just see
all y'all having all this fun like what
about us
when are we gonna have fun where do I
get to say yes it's been a while and
then to compound it with banner that's
the part that hurts and again in their
defense they did come out and say look
this was a mistake
they say they just say you know we
didn't intend for this PDE activity to
affect PvP in that manner but because of
the nature of the fix-it server side
they couldn't fix it in time and the
event to be over by the time they fix it
so I understand when they finally got in
front of it it's just like decision
making guys you should know never
introduced us into competitive crucible
you want to quit play have like a little
mayhem fun with it I'm all cool with
that yeah but you're not putting this in
competitive bro no no no no no so again
this is bungee being cute doing doing
foolish things and it's just I can't
thank you so how much what how many more
weeks before this reprobate - one more
week and shout out to be p.com no better
way to say that it's asking if the six
or seven minute runs on YouTube I
recorded a few of them we were chatting
over it but I
still may upload that one if you want to
see it basically what we did is I was a
Titan I think they might have been
warlocks or Titans but if you have
grenade grenadiers on which already
makes them hit harder and faster
we have Ark buff on so they were all
pulse grenades and then I had some
pieces of armor on as well I literally
could not hit Q fast enough as a Titan
because I have to could not hit you fast
enough to throw the grenade dude I'm
hearing reads the phone I'll give that
our raids are like I mean if you need to
run shattered thrown yes the way it's up
this week go turn that stuff on go break
the throne because it's just gonna be
insanity so I mean that is kind of crazy
it's a lot of like that's the stuff
that's that's what honestly like Ark we
should had yeah those types of things
like over crazy buffs or something weird
or just goofy stuff that's like you know
breaking the game but we're at a point
where things are kind of at a low mil a
moment but for those who do take a mode
seriously and it is a competitive points
where things can go up and down on your
rankings and things like take that crap
out of there everything else yeah have
fun be goofy go nuts like but yeah for
the especially the competitive part
where that is a serious playlist don't
touch it don't screw with that stuff
that's wow that's cool breaking my heart
was breaking while my rank was going and
I'm like I went down and I saw that
stuff like shinobu Saval just constantly
like I mean shadow to follow up being
like guys probably shouldn't do this but
this is what you can do it's hilarious
by the way oh yeah wait tc2 movie one of
the movie of the week stay outing I'm
just like oh this is the new thing now
so what we doing sad for it saying are
you telling me it's a good time to try
out that flawless run and shatter throne
I mean if you're ever gonna do it just a
week it's a good try but the only try
you're gonna have crazy crazy grenade
buffs like I'm into a point of being
broken yeah I forget I mean depending on
your build
like I know Titans if he got doom fing
pauldrons and Sentinel shout out the
esoteric I like I stood in the last five
the five bosses in the forest I just sat
there and threw my shield the entire
time he whispered he did a whisper run
with one super
ow one two three easy and I think he was
doing some of the boss or rooms or some
of the clears of sections of shattered
throat in the same way so I mean doom
Fang pauldrons and this with that
grenade buff nothing else turned on just
literally doom paintball dooms the super
in the grenade buff yeah you're not
gonna run out how glad you guys are
having fun yeah well I mean I agree with
you I'm just like it shouldn't mess with
your you shouldn't like I mean iron
banner honestly is it still like you
don't lose much in it the grenades like
that's kind of a weird mix territory
because I know you have your special
place for iron banner I know I know but
I'm saying you don't sucks
you don't lose like valor anything if
it's a weird match where people are
abusing it and I play bass and I'll say
I played a decent amount of iron banner
this week I've seen a few people doing
it but it might be like one person every
other match I don't actually see nearly
as apparent as a cop is literally
probably four shinobis valves just
throwing like insane down the hallway
which is just da no this disgusting this
all I got on it so ya won't beat
anything but I I'm on I am holding
to my stance unless I get tricked into
something unless you tell me some other
thing about something being Asajj she
said thrown I'm like okay shadowzone was
cool yeah but I'm like I'm not the bowl
guy so I'm like do I really care about
my thing right now like I was I was I'm
really the best man you've done in that
place right yeah okay they just under
yeah I've did it on a console I even
wish ender on a PC so it's something you
know I'm saying so so quick cuz a little
you if you blow through it once you get
the gift the quest yeah and then
literally just turn back around go do
the like whatever the mission is with
all those three bosses it'd be so easy
with their grenades it wouldn't take you
long like if I think you do have a
little time you got one other person
with you you'd be fine like I thought we
only thing I am tempted to do during
this whole craziness this every is
uh-huh what you call it I wanted my hit
pyro I'm I see how like one of them
raids is mmm
see how crazy yet with certain things
that the only thing I might do but his
slides can be interesting
and I'll probably login for user there
are waiting for user job and that's a
second - yeah absolutely so that's what
I got but shout out also to Bungie I
always enjoy their ride alongs yeah I'm
gonna be able to catch this one live but
they are doing a shattered thrown oh
yeah baby
you're gonna miss I'm gonna miss the
live version I'm gonna watch it later on
that night but oh you just got some you
got to do is I this is your cat he's got
work that night mm-hmm but no they're
gonna do a ride-along just like they do
in a raid talking about the inspirations
where they build where all the staff
coming from I want to see what insane
person built the Borg a fight but I also
want to see them because they develop
this and they have the triumphs in the
game for the solo the flawless and the
solo flawless they built this to be able
to do that and I want them hopefully to
talk about like what made them put those
like triumphs in there what made them
test this out what made them build this
so it was a three person raid but truly
solo bull like I mean they built it to
be that way it wasn't easy but they made
it to where it was and I kind of want to
know the whole thought process behind
that one so I'm really curious because
for me and all the content like last
wish was cool like the mechanics but for
me shadow throne was like that's my baby
[ __ ] baby yeah things since I came out I
wish there were more of them gasps I was
just about to say just the whole con I'm
curious to see the concept behind the
design on it and then you know like you
say like will we see more of it in
future because it's such a cool concept
and sometimes destiny Bungie does this
thing where it's this weird thing where
they introduce something so cool like
you just assume they're gonna continue
with it some and then you don't hear
from these things no more and it's just
like you know what happened that was you
know we like that like they do things
like this it's just so confusing so I
you want you would like to see the
thought process behind a dungeon 3-man
dungeon like you said the solo aspect
and just to see you know you know in the
future it's just something that they
want to plan in implementing it was
really yeah so tune in to that one if
you don't catch it live it'll be on
their twitch archives I'm sure they'll
put it up on the website so
watch it at some point definitely talk
about that one I'm thinking I was like I
don't know if next week I'm gonna be
able to actually I may be off the
podcast next week all that work is
trying to drag me in if we do it's gonna
be like an hour and then I'm gonna have
to duck out so we'll see might have to
be short and sweet one will find out we
work around you all right so next piece
the denial of the nine mm-hmm and this
is one of those points where I have to
facepalm for a couple of reasons as
absolutely a couple topics tomorrow the
seventh annotation of the nine which has
a Marie Diaz I'm right reading this
technically it's today because it's now
Friday in about three hours
invitation the nine the seventh one will
become available before this pursuit
goes live we'd like to make players
aware of a blocking issue or currently
working on tomorrow's invitation titled
the tower sorry if you guys are getting
the sarcasm or disgust in my voice right
now it's probably late on real thick
will require players to complete the
hollowed layer strike that's fine
defeat hive scorn and vex
well the tangle drawer currently this
invitation cannot be completed since vex
are not available as enemies at any
location on the tangled Shore this issue
does not impact previous invitations
than nine only the tower invitation is
currently blocked we are currently
working to resolve this issue as soon as
possible mmm seriously mmm this is just
great design man this is this is this is
the pinnacle of testing oh oh I'm gonna
hear this one I want to hear okay this
there's a couple weeks ago show PvE babe
I can't wait let's get started a couple
weeks ago in poor quest design when they
said hey let's put hive on Mercury and
I'm like wait hold on where the hell are
they and then Peter on Twitter are nice
enough to remind me you could
technically do it on an adventure I'm
like alright fair but but still
generally that's still not a good idea
exactly so this brings up a couple
issues with these invitations in line
one we've only had one cinematic since
the beginning so you set expectations
and now you've never had another one
again not spritzing one like in the
fourth or fifth if you save it for the
final one and then you're done it's
gonna be kind of a knowing book in
situation one more cinematic would have
gone a long way to just be like hey
there's one more in the middle okay got
one in the middle then maybe one more to
the quests designed so not creative go
to a bike a couple races kill you have
to get nine of these essences you're up
but it's random so you can't even like
know if you're shooting the right
enemies if you're on the right planet
and I actually killing the right ones
so that's annoying honestly an easy way
to fix it hey go to the EDC and shoot 50
enemies in the face or shoot a hundred
because you probably have to kill a
hundred to get these 9 essence to drop
like go make it something you track but
go make it to where it's not gonna be
limited by these weird things they made
three whoever made this quest and was
like oh yep that's approved didn't read
it clearly seriously like I'm sorry but
vex untangled short just have you played
you I know that I know they play their
game I know they play their game so how
on earth do you save vex are allowed in
the tangled sure how many looked at this
how many people approved this quest
pending signing off on these decisions
exactly every competitive stuff did like
how do you not know vex is not on the
tech who made the game like what you
said like that this is this is one of my
moments of frustration because I'm like
yeah putting this thing breaking
competitive crucible not smart at all
not knowing vex on tangled sure but like
vex on tangled short is fundamentally
built into your forsaken expansion for
eight months now that should not be news
it should not be news but also what's
annoyed me more is just the fact that
the the
lazy quest design it's been lazy quest
designed for every one of these pick a
strike kill some minis on the plant pick
a strike kill some money miss on a
planet you don't think with her a couple
windows now idea okay cool and then what
does the next one be like hey run these
for lost sectors and you gotta go check
them off the names are on the map now
it'd be something different hey go do
two lost sectors in a strike at least
some variety rides on it's the same
thing drip drip drip drip feet peak on
sit this way we get a d3 gonna be late
for those watching the video I'm sure
you enjoyed that but yeah so basically
you cannot do the invitation until they
fix this so we are locked at number
seven until they fix this so this just
pushes the cinematic if there is another
one which they said there was farther
and farther and farther and farther away
until it's fixed how long is it gonna
take to get fixed how long does it take
for them to change a bounty requirement
put it into out in the system put the
patches out and have everybody get that
update
let's see because this is actually this
is a small of a changes you can make
change one bounty requirement how long's
it going to take for us to get it
dramatic love the dance we're gonna send
out like a boomerang at Guardian con of
us just like we might have to record
that might need to go viral thing is
what actually makes me question bigger
things and this is what I was kind of
talking to you about whether it's
changes to the revelry whether it's this
fix and they're saying they're working
to resolve this issue as soon as
possible they can't say it's gonna be
even in the May patch I know how is that
not like guaranteed like a hundred
percent okay it's in there like how far
how far art no but it was like but also
like is okay so multiple issues like
this is this one's ignorance and I hate
using that word cuz that's a really kind
of deep cut on intelligence but vex on
tangle short it's pretty lacking in some
thought process
mm-hmm stacking on top of breaking
you're competitive
the one thing that you kind of want to
give people hope for hmm on top of like
spectral blades still being an issue
like how slow some of these are and this
is like so I'm acknowledging your your
annoyance of choices fully because we
talked about that yesterday I never said
that was wrong but for me is like if it
if they make the bad choices and can't
fix them quickly there are other issues
at hand and Liz and that's whoa that's
where I want to figure out what is going
on so whether it's like I was actually
listen to say no to rage she was talking
about the evil what he said I like to
say no to Ray that's my dude what do you
say it's like I don't know if he's too
big for us but I would like to get him
on here seems like just good job good
chat
he was just talking about like the I
guess the engine they use is the tiger
engine I never heard of it called
whatever it was it's just like the name
of the title I mean we're heard about
the old engine stuff in destiny one
where's like load up a map for eight
hours and then move a bush and the hope
it saves and like all those crazy things
overnight I mean there's a point where
like whatever they're working on for
destiny future they got to fix the
foundation level code on some of this
stuff to be able to adapt quicker adjust
things faster and those pieces need to
be able to change because things seem so
brokenly inner woven like to a point of
like I can't touch I can't touch this
weapon stats over here I'm gonna break
the shattered throne like I mean how far
how interlinked can stuff be that you
can't like I mean that was one I mean
anthem very broken we'll get there in a
little bit but they actually made it
swear they it's like literally here's
this thing here's a Lego brick we're
gonna bolt it onto the site and they can
add things like that and that's like and
bungees been too deep into their current
whatever they got so let me tell you
something
season of opulence better be late for
this bro season of opulence if we get
Wow of this of repetitive quest steps of
2 to 3 weeks before something get fixed
like it almost feels like everyone's on
vacation like what's up you don't say oh
man you shot the app deal he's like at
least it's about frostbite engine you
know I will say this on a positive note
obviously we know about the miss summit
you know for opulence we know that's
going down and I did here for you PvP
guys I know I've been crying there's a I
forget his name they seems cruel I
forget is he's one of the top PvP guys
on the ranks and leaderboard stuff like
that and he got invited just recently so
actually don't forget invited me he's
got a job at Bungie excuse me oh they
just hired him almost like a short-term
contract kind of deal kind of someone
what they do we like Holtz and those
guys I think exactly so when I see that
I say ok I'm getting some hopeful
appellants but we have to say right now
let's just let's just say my deal and so
it might be September on that yeah you
might be right to know you might be some
opulences vicarious right and opera but
there is I believe it was a summit
though wasn't this summit for I mean
there's a summit well to some extent we
get wonder what they're looking on like
I mean if vicarious has been working on
opulence and they're slowly starting to
you know get the code probably put
together I mean we're a month away
roughly so I mean I don't know how much
you're really gonna be changing when is
the summit a window summit like a couple
of weeks back so it almost feels like
how they had the summit and it was for
war mind and then forsaken right because
they saw showed them what warm I was
gonna do they make some change and then
they showed them the behind the curtain
of Forsaken and it is a hairy fix that
no don't do this you know I'm saying
and then forsaken was what forsaken was
and I'm saying so um yeah I mean I
they've got they've got they got some
work cut out man because I'm just gonna
call it a drifter season drifter
this is this is a failure fake folks
kind of what I said to you and it's like
in a bit of a poking way I feel like
we're now in the beta phase of destiny 3
because they're like I mean I said it
yesterday be like oh let's see if we can
do something that where we can have some
fun with this tonic and see what it's a
oh this is so oh crap we went too far we
got these set bonuses let's try this one
little place to see if they work okay we
got set bonuses they technically
function cool check that box all right
let's go throw that in the next night
they're like testing all these little
things and I feel like they're like
little features that they want to make
sure work they want to see how the code
functions or something like that because
honestly it's just like yeah no it's
destiny can't stop being a beta access
game people yelling at me up the
distance I'm dying to know the player
counts that's what I wanted I mean you
know how oh no don't play accounts
let's see those numbers let's give
behind the curtain there I was see how
like this if this is the route that we
gonna go yes because at the end of the
day it's just like got it you still got
to engage you still got to keep interest
you still have to keep a level of
consistency and at this rate man they
just pissing people off like they're
you're too like you to be eyes I don't
even realize the extent with the hoenn
with the 9 thing and here's the other
thing what should be really the payoff
for these invitations and outside of
that one cinema that we got right there
okay and they built us up so I'm like if
you give us that I'm cool and I'm saying
you really deep tower story it really
hasn't you know I'm saying and you know
we just got a call it what it is
season the drift is not ago and I will
say this like I'm almost at the point of
saying black armory was better I like to
as much as I didn't like the story
narrative loop of black armory the
gameplay loop was better I feel you know
saying they had your forges yeah just
stuff you had weapons to grind for every
week you can do different you know I'm
saying like it I just liked
a little more better in as I thought it
was more fun like drift unless you like
this gambit hardcore guy yeah it was
like oddly very focused there they
didn't throw in like and they haven't
they've done strikes they haven't on pvp
maps and this has been the weird thing
about it like they have done and this is
like their trial of features they're
like here's a feature we're gonna add to
this one but okay so I mean some of that
stuff takes a while to get out there but
didn't by the time you get it it's kind
of like and yes now shout out to
Vicarious Visions they did an awesome
job on the PC port couldn't play better
than butter oh yeah and this is their
swan song after this they're going back
to Activision they're done with destiny
so if they're gonna put a final end cap
on a piece of this game they've had the
longest time to work on it right they've
got you know they were part of the PC
all of these things so we've got a shot
that hopefully they've been working on
it for a while and we get some stuff
between both studios yeah don't get me
wrong about Negative Nancy as I've been
I feel I'm not gonna say super confident
like but I feel good that opulence
should be good you know saying and a
raise coming back so you know that's
always a good thing you know saying but
um yeah oh wow dramatic he says I'm a
hardcore gambit guy and I'm so so on
season oh wow that's a big statement
mm-hmm
and that's and that's kind of thing it's
like you have gambit
they have gambit Prime kind of an
evolution of it which was cool in theory
the limitation of some pieces the fact
that it's only annual pass like if you
want to be like hey gambit prime okay
annual pass safe you got it like a month
early but then hey throw game but prime
to the rest of the world so they can
kind of play it to build your player
base up cuz I mean you're they're
they're splitting player bases more and
more and more and more yeah which is
getting to be tough I mean Zayn you'll
pass or not but it's like if somebody
still just jumps on destiny and be like
oh this is new like you might have a few
more people in there the people who got
like the PC game for free who got some
of the expansions and things like just
let them try some of that stuff to know
what you're working on so I don't know
opulence has
has a little I wouldn't say it has a lot
of pressure on it because the hopes
honestly are not that high rare but it
does need to be something reasonable
because otherwise you it's you know
gonna be a struggle every last word you
get there what else we get when you
start playing Sakura we'll talk
Mortal Kombat had my attention this week
I'm a big motor company oh yeah how long
is you own Sakura though I'm sorry
[Laughter]
movies of the week there are some goofy
ones but yeah grenades are really busted
out there so that's obvious shout-out to
anything it was Carolina gamer who
posted it up the tripmine sparrows
strike insta boss skill was hilarious
yes so that one was actually really good
with a shout out that was definitely
well deserving so for creativity but
yeah so there is an emblem out there for
all of you insane people if you need the
wizened rebuke which sadly even doesn't
have the best rules but if you are a
collector you gotta get your 500 Burton
kills I think I'm at like 91 yeah takes
a while if you are insane and you want
to get 2500 iron Burton kills there is a
emblem that you can get kind of looks
cool but whoof
2500 kills to get in the eye with the
burden in iron banner live in an iron
banner and there's one more iron banner
the CNAs only one more year like that's
cool though I mean it does look cool but
not worth my time yeah I mean yeah at
this point like the revelry is I mean it
has some fun Pete like if you're gonna
go run strikes yeah go turn that stuff
on have a goofy blast enjoy it
now is there is there a reason to spend
your time in the verdant
probably not once you get your árboles
you're pretty much checking out of there
so it's kind of short-lived
there's no increasing difficulty level
500 the same as one like we've seen all
those pieces so I mean right now if
there's other things you need to grind
use the rebel right tonic because if I
do a strike I get 12 essence or whatever
do a couple you know quick strike runs
or something like that I have enough
essence that I don't lose any so if you
are actually speed running strikes you
can actually get stuff back pretty quick
so those are a good thing if you're
working on hitting boxes but other than
that like if you're enjoying stuff and
you know in destiny whether you're
working on your reckoner title if you're
working on certain things like then
enjoy them have fun let the game be
broken in PvP no don't let it be broken
in PvP you know let's not do that
but unfortunately gotta wait if you're
working on comp until this thing is done
mmm
and sadly you want to know the worst
part is what's that
the tonic I don't know if it goes away
or if it just stops being useful when
you run out of essence really yeah I'd
have to go back and read a previous one
but it's like the tonic is there dr.
Walley I know I've been trying to use
tonics but I'm up to 2,000 well he's
like I love how broken so many things
are for this event yeah and they wonder
why I'm not playing but yeah so it's
gonna be a little while till things
settle back into whatever is left of
this season so if you like a piece of
content if you just enjoy certain things
if you just do your Tuesday your Tuesday
run with friends and go play other stuff
and do what you're gonna do
so right now destiny is kind of in a
point to where enjoy the stuff that you
like and if you aren't enjoying it again
go step away that's by ji big Aloe Blacc
I think you suck now bring me out when
it's all over baby cuz I'm not mmm I
think I think yeh wake me up Aloe Blacc
that's that's the theme song for the
revelry wake me up when it's
Oh days gone came out that's kind of
okay reviews some people are saying like
the voice actors didn't awesome job but
the script is kind of okay the story is
okay but some of the gameplay gets in
way of the story like I hear some ups
and some downs even like skill up didn't
actually rip it apart
so I saw his laman he didn't do a full
review yet but his blaming gaming they
were saying it's actually kind of fun
and sometimes it's equations yeah
expectations kind of help that one not
be like hey we expect this thing to be
like amazing no they don't
so therefore if it's kind of fun then it
might be a nice break that's the same
that sometimes what you got to do games
that need breaks we're rolling into the
anthem shot oh let's get it let's get it
so and go no I for one had a really
rough stream because people did nothing
but ask about loot and they weren't
gonna touch it because they can't answer
it yet and basically most things for
anthem have been fairly delayed they
released the new stronghold sunken cell
it is available in all players who
complete with a critical path and
honestly they did a couple quality of
life things that are good
actually one Hugh one huge one but
there's a couple other medium ones too
and then added the ability to select
contracts from the start expedition
screen it's supposed to go on over to
like the boards or anything like that so
that's little and will get bigger mm-hmm
and have the ability to launch a new
mission from the end of the expedition
screen without having to return before
Tarsus oh that's even better than this
one is the big one let's go for what is
I had it the ability to access the forge
during mission strongholds and free play
you can now change your gear without
having to return to the fort I'm opposed
to anthem salute salute one of the
biggest changes we got to give credit
where credit is due
no I mean that is a huge fundamental
change to their to their game like some
end this what it came out in was it
February two months to go from the
foundation of like you have to go back
to the forge to like fix that type of
stuff to now being able to actually
change that stuff up
on the fly in a mission that's actually
a big one
so I mean anthem has a long ways to go
and I think it's pretty clear when you
look at anthem pretty much delaying
Cataclysm they have no date for which
honestly kind of figured they should
delay it anyway because it doesn't help
you to release a large piece of content
in a game that nobody is like that's not
even good spot you've got to have a
working game before you put more content
on it
yes so please yeah it's on life support
and it's like yeah the 100-dollar origin
axis well gaming Forte if you haven't
played inside yet that's when I
definitely recommend it's the sequel to
limbo if you have never played any of
those days and there's some other ones
we'll probably you let your access will
probably get you through whatever comes
out in September like that Star Wars
game maybe you think or the Nexus I'll
have that yes sir yes sir doesn't for my
good friends at respawn I respect those
dudes yeah I mean listen you know this
whole thing with the um you know the
updates first of all I just wanna like
the climate right now dude have you seen
them message boards when they put out
them updates yeah that's right it is so
toxic it is it is bad like I've met it's
it's really at its low point and me you
talked about this offline like I dare at
a point wait they just literally just
got to keep their head down I feel like
they should not pop up until something
is ready until something is you know and
they have tangible dates for when for
deliverables right cuz you don't want to
say hey we're doing this yo and
everybody's like okay we'll win when's
that happened just come up with
definitely just shut down just shut down
like they're gonna have to do to
Division one it was in a bad state you
just literally you're just working
towards updates and you do patch patch
work and then hopefully not gonna say I
have a check taken King on but they can
do a no man's sky moment where they just
went over from Diablo something like did
me when they finally have enough of the
quality of life stuff done that they
make and just really put out something
whether it be fall or you know fall of
this year or early next year however
long to take and then that's how they go
almost with a soft reboot and then just
try to build up the base because to me
the way I'm looking at the way they're
now right now we gotta say that this is
just
preparation eventually for anthem to the
way it probably should be and has to be
I'm saying dad that's where this is
going right now so you know at the end
of the day I just hope that ei doesn't
walk away from them we don't want my way
to go away we know about the situation
we know about the arc we can get into
that but um yeah it's not good it's not
good it's been a lot it's been a lot a
snafu but at least do these qualities
quality of life dates I think that's it
yeah I mean those are just basic
functions that are slowly gonna start to
get at it in this one's big
yeah I don't know if they're ever gonna
let you see your loot in the missions
you pick up that would be another one
that would be big next what I mean steps
like this show like that's a pretty
fundamental change to actually have to
put in just the way the actual game
works so that's that's a pretty
substantial change that they're able to
do so shows like I mean that's not like
hey let's check these light boxes we're
not sure how much we're supporting it
know they're making some pretty deep
changes so they are working hard so
shout out those guys definitely still I
mean they do not have an easy road ahead
I don't know if the road ahead actually
has light at the end of the tunnel right
now I really don't I don't know if ei
can even greenlight an anthem to until
they see what's there but they have to
actually be thinking about it otherwise
like you have to figure out what to do
with this whole IP and property you've
made but all in all it's like I didn't
even max out gear score in mine and I'll
kind of waiting on my like I dabble in
it occasionally made to arraign AM
anthem stream at some point to be like
hey where's that right now let me play a
little bit and just slowly eek up my my
level but I mean at this point the
fundamental flying and gameplay like
felt really cool but it's Lego let me go
like get a scratch-and-sniff snicker
it's like let me scratch it sounds good
for a minute okay this is the smell
faded okay let me go play something else
it's gonna be a shorter to play if I do
touch it right now so it might just be
like hey what's the new stronghold like
cool and that's probably about it so
yeah stronghold I want to see that a
little small file actually I do want to
see the catechol just want to see what
that is but yeah I'm mad no that's not
coming yeah so Cataclysm like there's no
date I mean and and that's the point
where we don't know what it was and we
won't know for quite a while so that's a
while
yeah so yeah so anthem I mean quality of
life still works but I mean they got a
long road ahead toxic chat like their
stream was brutal was rough it was just
nothing to loot loot loot stop stop wow
that's crazy but that's the one people
want if people are still actually trying
to play the game they just want the loot
to be worthwhile so and there's only
certain places to get like I mean Tassie
again summarizes things very well is
short succinct articles tend to get the
the high notes and just like there's no
point really playing much more than
grandmaster one master one there's one
about a job posting for loot guy they
might have I feel like I saw some hos
before Luke guys up if that's the case
this is going to be a while yeah like
this is gonna be a work we don't we lied
to eat you know so it's tough to play
yeah and then now the other one of all
the things that's going on out there the
division - have you been blame this much
lately or you've been playing anything
away a little bit late a little bit this
week but I've really got to get back in
I've been dying to get back in but I
just played a little cuz I think I had
Mortal Kombat drop this week days going
I'm picking I'm actually picking up cuz
I actually had a chance to yeah I'm a
sucker for this hobby thing some I'm
gonna try and I'm saying that's where I
actually pictured that on you yeah I've
always kind of liked them
low-key Walking Dead kind of guy so and
then this one kind of touches to series
for me so it's almost like walking dead
meat Sons Anna like I'm a huge son
strings more than on yeah I got the Jack
Stella Jackie going on my man you know
Saint deacons Saint John whatever
alright gotta see what's going on
you know but um yeah shout out to them
if you haven't seen it I had a interview
fella presentment
studio at PAX East so check that out on
our podcast YouTube channel days go on
taxis coverage really that three-part
series look is it perfect no I mean
there's definitely some issues but it
looked fun to me and I like resource
management so I'm gonna but enough about
that division so um
so yeah efficient too right now still no
is there a date on the raid yet or not
yet not yet I believe this is the last
patch before they put out on what you
call it the what is it uh open I always
butcher it uh operation dark hours
operation dark hours I believe you'd
ever say so this is the last update and
prior to that and it looks like um they
do uh some recalibration or some skill
mods stuff um on PC there's an issue
right now and apparently since their
last patch I think the 16th they had
some like increased loading times on pc
so they recognized that bug and they're
doing the whole public got the test
server
I believe so um yeah there's gonna be
this huge update and it's gonna be title
update 3 and um this is gonna be again
with the that's with the release of them
the operation dark hours which is a play
a raid so they're still working out the
kinks they're working out some stuff and
I don't know if you got the do you have
the highlights up as far as the other
bullet points for the last no I don't
actually if you've got um they're nuts
but yeah so pretty much it's like um ok
so this is what we're gonna be
implemented based on their feedback
all right so gear score range one drops
will now be more in line with your
agents current gear score so to get that
kind of corrected recalibration system
will be work as when you go to the table
either to include the new recalibration
score I'll bring your items no longer
increase the item gear score correct
directly but will gather or rather
increase the recalibration score up to
the max 100 high end gear marks are
being reworked this is a big one to be
more powerful and logical choice for
your agent by increasing their maximum
stat role that's a big ding specially
like mods are a big part of the game so
that part you know it's cool I'm
reintroducing a new type of skill mods
including called auxiliary batteries
which will include a skill power bonus
and then I believe they talking about
purchase of personal blueprints for
specialized in superior rarity mods all
existing blueprints will be moved over
to the inventory and then here's the key
ones that I know you talked about
earlier which was as far as ammo drops
alright so ammo drops are
been increased to ensure that agents do
not run out of ammo it's frequently on
higher difficulties on when roaming the
dark zones now this is cool but there's
still an issue going on and I don't mean
you talked about this which is
specialization that's one and that's
still a problem child to use out the
Tassie you know the problem right now is
that you you grind to level up your
character to get these specializations
sharpshooter what-have-you and these you
know these could be powerful
game-changer type stuff the problem is
you don't have enough ammo and then they
want you to do specific things to get
that ammo you do it and you still don't
get enough fo so that's the problem and
they've got to figure that out because
they are planning on introducing more
specializations left the current ones
aren't you know buffed up then what's
the point of this in-game tear thing you
know I'm saying so they've got to fix
that estes for me personally i think
that's something that really needs to be
addressed and yeah i mean they get to
that point now they go ahead to drop
this raid now I got I've been I've been
very put on we get to that point
I understand they want things balanced
and perfection but I get this thing out
there you got it what's your feel on
this whole bit the updates that you've
heard so far I mean from what I'm seeing
like they are trying to get things ready
I just keep hearing weird things let's
say I remember looking over even just in
the demo and stuff where everything
seemed to have like a plus and minus mmm
yes that was kind of why does everything
have to have a minus towards the a well
I could real quick I just give you think
the problem was with division one
without the minuses people who are
getting they were starting to make
really broken builds yeah and the
minuses I guess their way of trying to
bounce but it does it doesn't feel good
when you put something on and has a plus
and of mine so I'm with you on that
aspect but I know why they doing it
or like if you get a higher level the
minuses maybe a little less or something
well I also heard and this is again like
I haven't actually played because I was
working on sick heroes so much yeah
there was a point where they like change
some of the it was either mods or stats
or things so if the plus and minus maybe
the - wasn't as big but I also lowered
the amount of the plus as well like
things both sides down closer to zero is
that true yeah yeah that is true shout
to seek free he said he actually likes
to plus or minuses makes you move deeper
into it it does it does and again
they're just trying to do it for balance
but um they still got to tweak a little
bit in my opinion but you know we shall
see my main thing is don't ask
specialization yeah so I mean that was
the big thing I saw in the article and I
even noticed that too when I tried the
Sharpshooter for the demo and obviously
things have changed vastly since then
but Tassie said it well is like the way
this is set up it's like so I have a
giant shot I have a giant sniper rifle
but I have like four bullets or I have a
sniper rifle that I have a hundred and
fifty bullets so which one are we gonna
use yeah my gonna miss some shots with
both of them sure but which one I'm
afraid to use shots for save it for like
a boss fight movie yeah yeah and then
you don't use it as intended
it's a crossbow and then the grenade
launcher I don't know how those are
doing but like some of them and then as
you said if the ammo is not dropping
it's very scarce in the first place
they're worried about like breaking
things with it but if you can't use them
in the first place I don't know it
defeats the purpose of the grind let's
keep it real like it defeats the purpose
of the grind this is supposed to be your
your carrot on the end of the stick for
that character build so you want to feel
powerful right you want to have it's
it's the equivalent destiny you get like
you know this cool you know heavy weapon
right now and it's like you're not
giving me purpose there's no hair on the
ground right it's literally kind of
thing but so you take away the fun
factor of usage rate and you want people
to feel powerful you want you know it's
it's it's like when you're playing
destiny you have ammo in whatever that
thing is whether it's your prospector or
your your sleeper or you know whisper
you want to feel that power of that
weapon yeah yeah I mean that's kind of
what I've kind of gotten the feel of
from reading these things and catching
these old tidbits about it talking to
you a little bit all these pieces are
just the fact that like specializations
are good in theory but as you said if
you've got more come in with each act or
whatever's coming next for these little
mini yeah they've got three or more yeah
one per each and it's like
none of them have much of a function in
the first place like why why are you
making more yes I could make a really
big sniper rifle when you have an almost
exotic sniper rifle that's just as good
and you have a hundred bullets for it
instead of exact they've got to let it
let the fun gate open a little bit card
that you don't say I think it will come
you know I'm saying but I am surprised
that they're being so stingy with it at
this stage today they almost seem a
little too careful little too nervous a
little too you know
listen let's see what happens man I mean
they gotta get this right out now now
I'm at the point you said it you started
hitting that at last last word which was
like yo do you think they take a look
now getting a like bro you gotta get it
right out gotta get this no no if you
don't have like a date in mid May but
it's gonna be two months by the time the
thing probably comes out yeah I mean
people are still rocking fan base is
still strong supposedly but you know
date they don't want is like was it I
was talking to you or my brother or one
of my friends maybe twitch about players
I was looking at some point and that's
need to is sexually spilled over
division to really there it's not right
now I literally looked right now but
there was like I'm some evening I was
just playing and I was scrolling through
in Division two was like below witnesses
console population a PC public they're
right next to each other right now no
100 twitch oh I got worse division to
him and destiny to a rednecks to each
other really interesting and like
interest I was like some divisions above
it now but they're not they're both low
but neither of them are like that far
from each other I always feel though I
know I sound like I'm making excuses for
them I always feel like really a
streamable game to me to me it's it's
tactical but it's MMO tactical
it's not like Rainbow six times what you
want in you out and it's just tension
feel yeah you don't succeed kinda thing
have an audience
yeah I don't know I don't I don't feel
like like destiny is just like space
magic and boom and explosion and shout
out to catch an army because he's going
in he's his disrespected division is he
it's almost like I almost throw that's
dizzy masquerading
and another person cuz kitchen are we yo
salute to your division hate you holding
up for desi right now oh but you got
dizzy come back in the chat you a
haven't gonna be tag-team partners but
do it hey you're not gonna be able to
let me smell a little hopefully slow the
comeback but uh it's um you know I get
it I do I have to admit like destiny is
just such a it's a more funner gained a
more interesting more vaster kind of a
game to stream in my opinion but well it
is one of those things - I mean kitchen
said it earlier is like you've got even
ant if anthem like the game play an
anthem so much fun like it is fun but
it's like it's short-lived fun because
like you got the Ironman simulator
you're flying around the guns may not be
that great but like the abilities it's
the space magic piece of the sci-fi that
fer for the moments of watching
something can look really cool be like
and the skilled person can make
something like anthem something like
destiny with like moving around and
flying and jumping at supers and like
trading things versus like detective
will hide behind cover - to shoot high
by and cover shoot you shoot it is a tak
little shooter they nail what they're
going for
but again in the viewing aspect
especially on Twitch it's hard to like
get excited to be like oh here's a boss
fight yeah it was like it's just like
here's another Street or a corridor or
open field or like mission where you're
fighting you know more humans and stuff
so it is it's a different game and again
a lot of people do enjoy the tactical a
lot of people do enjoy the division and
the gear the grinding and all those
things it's like it did a lot of things
well but it is also the joys of games
being an escape games being a little
away from reality and there's a point
where some people be like I just want to
shoot a human in the face I mean it just
comes we've always said that that's
always been the fundamental thing with a
division player and a destiny player and
again you have to be more immersed into
that world you have to accept that
aspect and in the majority I think or
going to from a streaming standpoint are
going to lean more to blasting monsters
in the face right and to you know doing
that kind of thing you know I'm saying
I guess maybe if dr. moon was a little
bit more balanced or better then maybe
that could kind of catch me because I
could see people may be getting into
some type of a moment that but you know
for now that's just what it is but I'm
actually surprised about that
information glad you told me I didn't
know that about streaming them yeah so
but I mean also when you talk about the
dark zone it's like there's another
buddy of mine he's playing division and
stuff like that when you talk about the
dark so he's like occupied is useless we
really just camp with the doors ah
there's no turret so you just camp the
door so why even go in Wow well-balanced
Andre more balanced on route what was
like honestly there's a point where it's
like just to let people in but crazy
people who go in there's a pack hey go
in if your camp on the door it might be
hard to get out but if you get out there
and run for a while fun then you get
your balance like even the dark zone
little PvP you got the turrets on the
doors okay I still don't honestly see
why you can't put a PvE one in the
corner you got three I mean that's kind
of the thing like you have eat you like
in division well I mean we both have at
some point I've asked for it when like
in Division one it was one big area so
it is harder to segment it but as they
truly have three the rotation would be
so easy at this point so go I like
occupied normal like normalized my TV
only PvE yeah must have that rotation
because the other thing I saw TAS he was
saying is that like now until the raid
comes out which we still don't have a
date on highest resource the highest
gear score stuff
yeah where's that at again yeah it's in
the dark zone said the dog zone and that
takes me back to division one of being
frustrating been like getting camp
trying to get only the highest level
stuff has come from this one place and
I'm like that's where you're gonna start
pissing me off so it's like there's a
long on it there's a ton of stuff to do
up to there like you might be able to
get to 505 15 as maybe what's in the DZ
and then find but if the only way to do
that is places where you getting Campton
trolled it just annoys me I mean that's
a lot of what those occupied it of
division agents sir why are you going up
against these these money's here on
lone wolf exactly that's see this is a
this is a Baucus issue he refuses to
play them but my buddy plays your groups
all the time he's at the same mentality
but you are now playing with groups you
know I'm fully aware I'm not solo player
for sure hundred percent but if you want
to give more people some options I'm not
taking away your experience I just give
everyone a rotation who I and it doesn't
hurt your experience at all you still
have a dark zone you can go into every
week it'll change so I don't take away
your experience I just add an option for
people who want some and some like it
just a PvE option to go in for me it's
just a way to be like hey go in at least
know where things are at I know where to
look for things I know I mean if I go
into the dark zone now I might not even
get to explore that much and know where
things are because I get killed so but
it gives you more of a freedom school
where they kind of give you the preview
of the dark zone you might be able to do
it one time but you can't just go in
there on a consistent basis he said
makes so little great again listen we
gotta get about to some agents we got to
sign him up to get a nice little group
so that he's not getting robbed in
trolls we got to hook them up man we
gonna make this petition so he can try
it as a formative way it is intended
can't be going out there solo many
streets are rough it's rough man
yeah so I think that's what I mean
that's what we got for the week actually
wasn't crazy long so for a change
shadow right kin for your question he's
just saying I hope they don't tie
another title to I just don't tie
another title to a flawless raid mmm
like because my brother for blacksmith
he's just like he's just destroyed cuz
he I mean he played those for dislike
till he was blue in the face
Wow but unless you do a flawless raid
that's both blacksmith and what's the
one for last wish oh yeah it's the
Petrus a run is what it is but that's
like one of the it you couldn't do all
the other things but if you can't get a
flawless raid team together with guitar
errors being an issue
yeah and stuff like that it's just like
it's been I know people in
Oh God I don't think pyro has the
flawless pyro doesn't as much as he runs
I don't know if he has a flaw he'll
radon I don't know I haven't asked him
ribbons baton that Sloan is thinking of
only thing that man don't got which is
funny is you see his tweets about
thousand voices yeah yo his doubt he's
unlike another three days a week no
thousand voices unlike run sixty
something or whatever he's just been
doing it since he got him since he got a
consistent rate group on PC has run last
wish three times every week and can I
get that game day I'm gonna drop yo
shadow but we got to get pyro on I know
he's always worried like cuz he's always
worried it's just like I don't know he
would be hilarious on here so we gotta
give power or ladies re yeah that I can
I can chastise him on his crotas in
something I need to chastise him is a
chill one today I mean there's not a lot
going on in all these things right now
waiting on the raid waiting on opulence
news yes sir sir just wake up number II
huh operation boy huh Trevor God
stay strong y'all stay strong keep that
player Carol oh no that's fine but I was
like if you need to go check some boxes
and PVE stuff go use the broken stuff to
do that absolutely so like I mean I got
Bray Tech Osprey and [ __ ] least and I
was like doom got the curator on both I
seen it I seen it yeah yeah those like I
mean have fun where it is fun but if you
like if you go into PvP like this sucks
just leave oh don't do in there so oh
yeah have fun out there guys
enjoy the movie that has been released
yes I go see it too mom I'm gonna yeah
that's Sunday morning at like 11:00 and
then Sunday night at like 8:00 for me is
Game of Thrones that is an emotional
roller coaster of a song ready right
well it's gonna be rough but it's gonna
be uh it's a lot of fun so enjoy
everything out there guys enjoy the
weekend of entertainment it's a it's a
good time to be a nerd and a yes one in
tune with all these fun things it's a
good coaches on a rise baby
we'll have a good one enjoy that's where
we're gonna wrap this thing up we gotta
do this timing right so I want to do
three two is a delay I listened to the
thing it's not awful there's a delay cuz
when you're doing it I don't know if
it's what we're using but they I noticed
why I was late because I was like oh wow
it's a delay when you say no and I heard
it so yeah we - I don't know that's we
can't read so if I do three to one I
need you to like say would tell me when
you hear three all right three two
why don't it and this is the last word
so that so wait hold on so if I go five
four three two one
say five loud when I say five so five
fire you're that far behind you're like
half a second like half a second how so
I have to be super quick yep
alright guys let's see if we can wrap
this thing up there's gonna be rough
with the delay so and that is the
podcast guys so this is a little last
word nice all right let's see I - jumper
hey yeah yeah hey see you guys have a
good one